let's get guys listen to learn your skin
don't get burnt I mean come in come in
I'm gonna now test you like never before
we're gonna cook restaurant standard
food and we were set up a 50-seat
restaurant upstairs in the chapel and we
gonna cook for some serious individuals
and we going up a notch at big time my
guess 50 influential catering industry
bigwigs including major players from the
fast-growing coffee shop sector
potential customers for the slice it's
time to shine once these industry
bigwigs are through the door my plan is
to first schmooze them with three
courses of restaurant quality food now
we're Syria main course the bad boys
bakery take on beef wellington made with
the best Phyllis steak and wrapped with
Parma ham and a savory crepe
I want them thin almost like a little
Neil Perry knickers Anthony yeah
Finn what was that time we had to pay
them in your hands
yeah uh yeah Jesus that first night when
you get out big man pace yourself pace
yourself my son
think about it having dinner starter
main course dessert to demonstrate the
professionalism of my team
the Wellington has to be cooked to
perfection let me tell you we can't [ __ ]
this up
we slice through that Wellington it's
gotta be pink let's go guys please
near the Sabbath and they were really
cooks for people of Simon family and
that forty year old David Jones is one
of my best chefs but after leaving the
army he got addicted to heroin you know
I have been coming in and out of Prisons
for a long time now and I see this and
getting old in our life and I want to
change ditch means a hell of a lot to me
I'm determined to fail
I wish hapless her Sam showed the same
dedication that they actually come to
life smart yeah
not next month yeah let's go rock up the
ass
despite my best efforts he still got a
lot to learn
nor the drowning it's just swimming in
the stuff the first time I ever tried to
cook beans on toast and they're not
burning my ex-girlfriends flat fiber
gate coming down cookies know many more
things it's gonna be firm guys really
tomorrow I need everyone pulling
together so I've decided to pair up
weaker team members like Hassan with the
older wiser heads only to bond work as a
team
David Jones you're working with Hassan
or on your table you have the head of
one of the most successful catering
companies in the country you have some
very serious individuals that you need
to impress better a marvel to the mark
tomorrow's volunteer
reform junkie David Jones isn't happy
he's working with drug dealer Hassan
I'll start to push him a bit exit out
tomorrow it's Keeble to the level we'll
start life I'm used to
you know understanded that i want so i
don't want a full thirty-minute dinner
dinner yeah David however when you have
them okay now like yeah but I've done my
staff and everyone interferes and then
it just all escalated in this I said
what you want brownie points for every
ball you wash up